the Tesla truck could be a game-changer
but it is obviously not the only
remarkable invention an innovation to
make a debut this year the editors of
Time magazine have compiled a list and
the top 25 are featured in this week's
cover story the 25 best inventions of
2017 they ranged from life-saving
innovations to lifestyle innovations
like a drone they say puts the selfie
stick to shame taking airborne photos
and video from an easy to control craft
that recognizes hand gestures here to
tell us about all other items that made
the cut is time science editor Jeffrey
Kluger Jeffery good morning good morning
I'm very excited about this I'm very
terrified about that's an even balance
everybody feels the both of those things
all right so let's start with the multi
elevator this is an industry that hasn't
undergone a whole lot of change yeah
long time yeah when your business model
goes back to 1888
there's something about refreshing your
your inventory list this elevator works
both horizontally and vertically you can
have elevators they in tall towers that
have horizontal connections between them
you can go back and forth it works
through magnetic levitation more less
than cables and the cars are actually
able to pass one another in the same
shaft which means you reduce traffic you
increase speed and you increase the
flexibility of your building design
you'll never get stuck in one you will
never get second well we're gonna work
on that car you'll see ok next up is the
esight 3 those are glasses that some
people have called the most powerful
pair in the world and they're for the
blind they are for the blind they are
for the legally blind so if you're
totally blind unfortunately these won't
work for you but what they do is they
have an algorithm that refines clarity
refines contrast and refined zoom so you
can intensify the visual image coming in
these glasses can actually allow legally
blind people to play sports they're
expensive just under ten thousand
dollars for a pair but the company is
helping to connect potential patients
with funding sources and grant system
exactly oh that's really impressive we
mentioned Tesla's electric semi-truck
but what made your list from Tesla
their new model three that's right and
here we are in an industry that still is
competing with a global total of 1.2
billion conventional cars as opposed to
2 million electric now the reason for
that in part is price point and range
but Tesla is tackling that by bringing
the cost of this model down to $35,000
which is competitive and allowing a
range of 200 miles on a single charge
which is basically what the Chevy Volt
has increased has has achieved they're
having a very good problem right now
they're getting 1,800 orders a day which
they can't keep up with musk says Elon
Musk says we are in production hell
right maybe that's a good place to be ok
one of the coolest items on the list is
michelin's new concept tire which is
called the vision what is it and does
spider-man have these on his car it
certainly looks like spider-man created
them this eliminates the key feature of
tires air they are non inflatable
they're made out of recycled materials
and the tread is 3d printed so if it's
dry in your city one day and snowy the
next day you don't have to change the
tires you just swap out the tread
covering and you're good to go
and those treads also have sensors in
them so that when your tread is wearing
down you get alerted time to change
anything next up a redesign of the
standard football helmet
0 1 the 0 1 and this is critical among
children alone people under 19 years old
there are 300,000 sports related
traumatic head injuries each year one
way of dealing with this is to redesign
the helmet this helmet is made not of a
hard shell but of a softer more flexible
polymer it was designed like so many
great things are by a pediatric
neurosurgeon on the back of a bar napkin
there are now players from 20 college
teams and 18 NFL teams using it
including Alec Smith of the Kansas City
Chiefs ok and really quickly before we
finish up Mars NASA is planning another
mission to the red planet with the Mars
insight Lander tell us about it this is
going to be a very sweet moon now we are
all spoiled by Mars rovers that go and
toddle around the planet this will be
stationary but for a reason
it's
to hammer a 16-foot probe deep into the
Martian surface to learn more about
Marsha Mart about Mars's thermal history
it will be detecting the planets wobble
the planet's internal composition
basically this will be a full category I
love it Jeffrey Krueger it's a brave new
world thank you for that sir thank you
for having